>>> TOPPING OUR TECHEAD TODAY,
A WEB OF HATE.
KIWI FARMS, AN ONLINE FORUM THAT
PRIDES ITSELF ON FREE SPEECH,
WHICH INCLUDES A LOT OF PURE
BIGOTRY AND HARASSMENT, KIWI
FARMS HAS BEEN DROPPED BY ITS
INTERNET SERVICES COMPANY AFTER
BEING LINKED TO VIOLENT THREATS.
THE SAN FRANCISCO BASED CLOUD
FAIR DROPPED THEM ONLY AFTER
NEGATIVE PRESS ATTENTION, WE
SHOULD NOTE.
FOR NEARLY A DECADE, KIWI FARMS
HAS BEEN A PLACE FOR ONLINE
TROLLS TO ORGANIZE HACKING AND
HARASSMENT CAMPAIGNS, SOME OF
THE VICTIMS OF WHICH EVENTUALLY
DIED BY SUICIDE.
CNN'S DONIE O'SULLIVAN TRAVELED
TO BELFAST IN NORTHERN IRELAND
TO BRING US THE STORY OF HOW ONE
TRANS ACTIVIST AND POPULAR
ONLINE GAMER TARGETED BY KIWI
FARMS LAUNCHED A CAMPAIGN TO GET
KIWI FARMS TAKEN DOWN FROM THE
INTERNET.
>> I WENT INTO THE HALLWAY, THEY
TOLD ME TO PUT MY HANDS UP.
HONESTLY IN THAT MOMENT, I
THOUGHT I WAS GOING TO DIE.
I SCREAMED AS SOON AS I SAW THE
GUN.
>> CLARA RECOUNTS HOW ONLINE
TROLLS CALLED IN A FAKE
EMERGENCY, SENDING ARMED POLICE
TO HER HOME IN CANADA, A TACTIC
KNOWN AS SWATTING.
OVER THE PAST MONTH, SHE'S BEEN
TARGETED, HARASSED, AND STALKED
AROUND THE GLOBE.
>> I'M SO EXHAUSTED OF HAVING TO
CONSTANTLY RUN.
>> SHE'S A TRANS ACTIVIST AND
STREAMER ON TWITCH, A PLATFORM
HUGELY POPULAR AMONG VIDEO
GAMERS.
>> HELLO.
>> EARLIER THIS YEAR WHEN SHE
BEGAN USING THE PLATFORM TO TALK
ABOUT TRANS RIGHTS, SHE CAUGHT
THE ATTENTION OF KIWI FARMS, A
NOTORIOUS ONLINE FORUM USED TO
ORGANIZE TRANS PHOBIC HARASSMENT
CAMPAIGNS.
>> THE FIRST THING THEY DID WAS
FIND THE OBITUARY FOR MY DEAD
FATHER AND USE IT TO FIND HIS
MEMORIALIZED FACEBOOK PAGE.
THEY WERE ABLE TO FIND A PICTURE
OF MY DAD ON THE FRONT PORCH OF
MY CHILDHOOD HOME AND FROM THAT,
USE GOOGLE MAPS AND FIGURE OUT
WHERE THAT WAS LOCATED.
>> AFTER HER HOME IN ONTARIO WAS
SWATTED, SHE MOVED TO A NEARBY
HOTEL, BUT HER HARASSERS TRACKED
HER DOWN THERE.
REMARKABLY USING THIS PHOTO OF
HER CAT ON HER HOTEL BED.
>> THEY WERE ABLE TO CROSS
REFERENCE WHAT THEY SAW ON THE
BED SHEETS WITH EVERY OTHER
HOTEL IN THE CITY UNTIL THEY
FOUND OUT THE SPECIFIC BED
SHEETS ONLY HAD A PATTERN IN
THIS ONE HOTEL THAT I WAS
STAYING AT.
>> EVENTUALLY, SHE SAYS HER UBER
ACCOUNT WAS HACKED ALLOWING THE
ONLINE BULLIES TO TRACK HER
LOCATION.
IT'S THEN SHE DECIDED TO LEAVE
CANADA, COMING HERE TO BELFAST
IN NORTHERN IRELAND TO STAY WITH
A FRIEND.
>> I THOUGHT IF I GOT FAR AWAY
AND WENT TO A DIFFERENT
CONTINENT, THEY WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO DO THE SAME THING.
AND THEN IT TURNED OUT I WAS
WRONG.
>> SOMEHOW, HER HARASSERS
TRACKED HER DOWN IN BELFAST, ONE
OF THEM EVEN CAME TO THE
APARTMENT BUILDING SHE IS
STAYING AT, TAKING THIS CHILLING
PHOTO FULL OF TRANS SLURS AND
POSTED IT ONLINE.
>> CLARA WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
STREAM ON TWITCH.
AND IN THE MIDDLE OF IT, WE FIND
OUT THAT ON THE WEBSITE FOUR
CHAN, SOMEONE HAD POSTED A
PICTURE TAKEN FROM RIGHT AROUND
HERE.
>> PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
GET THIS SITE OFF LINE FOR
NEARLY A DECADE.
>> SHE DECIDED TO TAKE THE
TROLLS ON, LAUNCHING A CAMPAIGN
TO GET KIWI FARMS TAKEN OFF THE
INTERNET.
>> I KNOW THAT THERE'S ALWAYS A
THREAT AGAINST ME AS LONG AS I'M
STANDING UP FOR THIS.
THE ALTERNATIVE WOULD HAVE BEEN
THE SITE KEEPS GOING, AND NOT
ONLY ME BUT THE COUNTLESS OTHER
VICTIMS OF THE SITE.
YOU GET HARASSED RELENTLESSLY
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> SHE CALLED FOR CLOUD FLAIR, A
MAJOR U.S. INTERNET COMPANY TO
STOP PROVIDING CYBERSECURITY
SERVICES TO KIWI FARMS.
CLOUD FLARE INITIALLY SAID NO
BUT THEN REVERSED TRACK OVER THE
WEEKEND, CITING IMMINENT THREATS
TO HUMAN LIFE.
SHE KNOWS GETTING KIWI FARMS
TAKEN OFF LINE WON'T MAKE ALL
HER TROLLS AND HARASSERS GO
AWAY.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING THIS TO
YOU?
>> I DON'T BLAME THEM, REALLY.
BECAUSE --
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH.
THEY GOT ROPED INTO A HATE
GROUP.
AND ONCE YOU GET DEEP ENOUGH
INSIDE ONE OF THESE THINGS, IT'S
REALLY HARD TO GET OUT.
I WANT TO SHOW THEM MORE
COMPASSION THAN THEY HAVE EVER
SHOWN ME.
>> NOW, JAKE, MOST OF US HAVE
NEVER HEARD OF COMPANIES LIKE
CLOUD FLARE, BUT THEY PLAY SUCH
AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN KEEPING A
LOT OF THE INTERNET RUNNING.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN THE PAST FEW
YEARS IS A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
COMPANIES LIKE FACEBOOK AND
TWITTER BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE DECISIONS THEY MAKE
ABOUT HATE AND VIOLENT RHETORIC
ON THEIR WEBSITES.
THIS IS REALLY WHAT SHE'S DOING
HERE, PUTTING THE NEW FRONTIER,
BRINGING MORE ACCOUNTABILITY TO
THESE TYPES OF COMPANIES